[Música]
[Aplausos]
sorria você está sendo filmada
hoje em dia a gente nem precisa mais ver
essa frase colada por aí porque a gente
sabe que em todo lugar a gente está
sendo filmada numa espécie de big
brother constante mas a gente está tão
acostumada com isso que a gente nem liga
mais se tem um celular apontado pra
gente na rua ou câmeras de segurança
filmando os nossos passos o tempo todo
porque essas imagens vão ser apagadas ou
esquecidas a qualquer momento na mesma
mas vocês já pararam pra imaginar que
existem câmeras que filmam o nosso rosto
o nosso corpo
nossos gestos e nossas atitudes e até
mesmo a nossa intimidade diariamente e
essas imagens ficam gravadas para sempre
as câmeras são essas são os olhos dos
nossos filhos o tempo todo mesmo quando
nem imaginamos e registram tudo na
memória construindo a história da nossa
vida que vai servir de modelo para a
história da vida deles
e qual é o tipo de história que a gente
quer gravar na mente dos nossos filhos
uma história triste cheia de brigas
desunião solidão uma história feliz com
uma família unida cheia de amor
compreensão união
se você escolheu a segunda opção eu vou
te contar uma forma divertida de fazer
isso vocês ou os filhos de vocês já
participaram de olimpíadas escolares já
perceberam como as crianças ficam
empolgadíssimas com a formação das
equipes
a criação do nome para os times às vezes
elas criam até escudo zinos gritos de
guerra
que tal a gente usar essa empolgação das
crianças para transformar nossa família
em uma equipe nós mães e pais seríamos
os técnicos da equipe com a missão de
orientar os jogadores nossos
filhos durante todo o processo mas a
gente não pode esquecer que os técnicos
não está nessa posição só para dar a
ordem eles fazem parte da equipe e
precisam se envolver também com muita
amizade e cumplicidade
o primeiro passo para criar uma equipe é
criar um nome que identifica o grupo
envolvam os filhos de vocês para criar
um nome para a família de vocês faça um
brainstorm com eles provavelmente
primeiro vocês vão fazer uma combinação
com o sobrenome de vocês para criar esse
nome para a família mas eu sugiro que
vocês continuem pensando até criar um
nome criativo que identifique a família
eu e meu marido depois que tivemos
amanda nossa primeira filha
começamos o processo exatamente dessa
forma
combinando nossos sobrenomes para
identificar a nossa família mas a gente
queria alguma coisa mais original
então depois que a notícia nasceu e nos
tornamos 4
a gente criou o nome família quadrada
representando os quatro lados do nosso
quadrado
depois que vocês criarem um nome que
identifica a família de vocês de forma
satisfatória é hora de partir para o
segundo passo é criar um grito de guerra
para time que vai se transformar no lema
da sua família
escolha uma frase forte e fácil de ser
memorizado e repetida por vocês e pelas
crianças
o lema da minha família a gente escolheu
quando a gente ainda era namorado ainda
marcelo
a gente viu uma frase de um carro que
dizia que a gente gostou tanto da
mensagem essa frase passa logo logo a
gente pegou ela para ser o nosso lema
desde então principalmente quando
acontece alguma coisa que começa a
prejudicar o relacionamento da nossa
família tendo lema tão bem definido para
que a identidade da família de vocês se
torne algo visual e assim se torne mais
fácil de memorizar tanto para vocês pois
tática para suas crianças como para as
pessoas de fora da família também
a nossa logo foi criada com base no
significado que a gente deu para o nome
família quadrada
então nós quatro viram os quadradinhos e
incluímos o lema da nossa família na
logo também como vocês podem perceber eu
tô grávida total de oito meses e vem
mais uma menininha por aí a pergunta que
a gente mais ouviu até agora foi e agora
a família quadrado vai virar família
pentagonal mas esse nome família
quadrada já está tão dentro de nós como
parte da nossa família e tanta gente já
nos conhece por esse nome que a priscila
virou mais uma quadradinha dentro da
nossa logo nossa luta continua sendo a
família quadrado tendo a identidade
formada a família de vocês é hora de
preparar o time no dia a dia para os
jogos que virão pela frente
nesse passo o técnico tem a missão de
promover reuniões para estreitar o
relacionamento da amizade e cumplicidade
entre os membros da equipe e passar
orientações e decide as táticas que
serão utilizadas ao longo de todos os
jogos
fazendo um paralelo do espaço com a
família
o horário das refeições são ótimos
momentos para essas reuniões para tornar
a família mais próxima mais unida
vocês devem fazer as refeições juntos
sentados à mesa mas sem eletrônicos
ligados com a intenção de conversar e
decidir assuntos são importantes para a
família como um todo
muitas famílias não conseguem ter esses
momentos de reunião porque os horários
não batem
mas é muito importante a gente fazer um
esforço adicional para ter pelo menos um
momento de reunião com a família no dia
seja onde for e um lanche de 15 minutos
à noite por exemplo a gente pode
identificar alguma coisa que está
incomodando os nossos filhos alguma
paixão que está aparecendo no coração
deles alguma coisa que eles conquistaram
a gente deve elogiar valorizar celebrar
além de conhecer quais são as amizades
deles quais são os gostos das
preferências
visão fazendo pela internet e se for o
caso
salvá los a tempo dos perigos que a
gente sabe que tem por aí eu sei que às
vezes a gente chega empolgada destino
para os nossos filhos pergunta e aí como
foi seu dia ea resposta é um seco legal
ou a igual aos outros dias
nessa situação é nosso dever como mães e
pais a procurar outras formas de
alcançar os pensamentos dos nossos
filhos
lá em casa a gente já testou algumas
coisas que deram certo
muitas vezes eu eo marcelo começamos a
contar como foi o nosso dia e as meninas
acabam usando nosso exemplo e contando
como foi o dia delas também sem a gente
precisa perguntar nada
hoje em dia depois de muitos anos
fazendo isso às vezes tem até briga para
ver quem vai falar primeiro
muitas vezes também em vez de a gente
fazer a pergunta genérica como foi seu
dia
a gente procura ser mais específico
pergunta algo do tipo de coisa mais
engraçada que aconteceu com você hoje ou
alguma coisa que te deixou triste
chateada hoje e de tempos em tempos a
gente faz uma espécie de jogo em família
também
todo dia à noite cada um de nós deve
contar qual foi a coisa mais legal ea
coisa mais chata que aconteceu no seu
dia
esse tipo de jogo é interessante porque
além de a gente se conhecer melhor a
gente acaba prestando mais atenção em
tudo que acontece ao longo do nosso dia
porque a gente tem o dever de contar
duas situações específicas que nos
aconteceram para o restante da família
de noite se conhecendo melhor
a família se torna muito mais unida e
entrosado outra forma simples mas que
nem passa pela cabeça dos pais hoje em
dia de fazer essa união entre a família
é manter a tv eo computador somente na
sala da casa
lá em casa a gente nunca colocou a tv
nem no nosso quarto nem no quarto das
meninas
é claro que eu e marcelo tivemos que
mudar alguns hábitos que tínhamos antes
dela
serem tivemos que parar de ver alguns
programas que são inadequados para as
crianças mas a aproximação que a gente
tem com elas por conta dessa atitude é
enorme e vale muito a pena
amanda está com 12 anos e no ano passado
assistiu a uma série chamada grave falsa
na época a gente procurou saber sobre o
que era sério viu que era adequado para
a idade dela mas a gente não assistiu
junto com ela
o problema é que ela gostava de contar
coisas sobre a série pra gente e como a
gente não conhecia os personagens nem o
roteiro da história
a gente entende bulhufas do que ela está
falando então a gente viu mais uma
oportunidade de aproximação com ela e o
marcelo falou que gostaria de assistir a
um episódio por dia dessa série junto
com ela ela adorou a idéia e isso gerou
mais um momento de intimidade entre pai
e filha
e vendo resultado positivo dessa atitude
eu confesso que fiquei com um ciuminho e
decidi que também vou querer assistir
algumas séries junto com ela e leticia
agora o time já está bem preparado é
hora de entrar em campo e jogar e esse
passa a gente deve jogar mesmo com as
crianças
existem diversos tipos de jogos que
desenvolvem características que nossas
crianças vão precisar ao longo da vida
alguns jogos de tabuleiro por exemplo
desenvolvem o senso de competição entre
os filhos e aí a eles aprendem que às
vezes a gente ganha e às vezes a gente
perde aprendendo assim a lidar com as
frustrações outros tipos de jogos
desenvolvem a formação de equipe a
cooperação o foco a tomada rápida de
decisões enfim existem diversos tipos de
jogos para todos os gostos e eu sugiro
fortemente que vocês
experimentei os mais variados tipos de
jogos de tabuleiro com seus filhos e seu
filho gosta de jogar videogame se
aventura a jogar com ele peça para ele
me ensinar
se você não tiver jeito nenhum para
jogos eletrônicos pelo menos vocês vão
dar boas risadas juntos uma vez eu pedi
pra mandar me ensinar a jogar minecraft
no computador mas ela apertava
santa tecla mesmo tempo isso tudo junto
com o mouse que eu não consegui fazer um
bonequinho nem andar direito que irá
construir alguma coisa qualquer e blocos
lá eu desisti é claro mas nós demos boas
risadas juntos depois que o otimismo
entra em campo joga é hora de celebrar
as conquistas
vocês devem lembrar de uma famosa
comemoração que o bebeto fez na copa de
94 quando ele fez um gol e ele ficou
balançando os braços no ar como se
estivesse embalando um bebê no colo que
representava o filho recém-nascido dele
assim como esse gesto diversas outras
comemorações já entraram para a história
a gente também pode inventar uma um tipo
de comemoração para celebrar as
conquistas da nossa família
lá em casa quando a gente quer comemorar
alguma coisa a gente dá um abraço da
família quadrada
nós quatro nos abraçamos em circo e
ficamos gritando e rodando girando e
gritando o nome da nossa família
por fim todo time de sucesso tem uma
sala onde ficam expostos os troféus que
o time ganhou ao longo do tempo a gente
também pode fazer algo equivalente a uma
sala de troféus na nossa casa
alguns anos a gente criou a árvore das
realizações lá em casa todo mês de
dezembro quando a gente monta nossa
árvore de natal em vez de enchê lá só de
enfeites e presentes a gente pendura
nela cartõezinhos onde cada um de nós
escreve com as folhas realizações mais
importantes daquele ano
esse é um momento muito esperado por nós
porque a gente relembra tudo o que nos
aconteceu durante o ano e foca nas
coisas mais importantes que a gente
precisa celebrar dá uma satisfação é
incrível ver os cartões vizinhos que
cada uma nota e olhar para a nossa
árvore todos os dias e perceber um
pedacinho da história que a nossa
família está escrevendo a nossa árvore
fica tão linda que a gente não consegue
desmontá lo antes do carnaval a gente só
percebe que fez história quando para
recordá la
e quando terminamos de recordar a gente
percebe que as maravilhas de se ter uma
família não estão na compra de uma casa
um carro ou naquele emprego que te dá um
bom salário mas sim no que a gente vive
com os nossos filhos no dia a dia e essa
vida que devemos apresentar para os
olhos deles filmarem registrarem e
recordarem para sempre porque nenhum
sucesso no mundo compensa o fracasso no
lar
obrigado
[Aplausos]